you're here here you got lots changed
for you in a short amount of time we got
my biggest interview to date now here
with you the wonderful Lauren Zima so
I'm excited to be here
yeah a wife's different yeah it's been
far that's been good no I never thought
it would blow up to this extent but so
grateful for the experience it's been
you know life-changing well let's talk
about what else is going on in your life
let's do it you know you had that final
drink with Hanna mm-hmm and then we saw
some very public photos of you and Gigi
Hadid yeah so where are you guys at
right now who you and Gigi uh we're just
we're just friends we're just friends
patient yeah our relationship is need to
be public it's she's good she's good
people she's an amazing person and we're
just keeping it keeping it friendly are
you in love with a supermodel Tyler
camera and I at the point where I don't
really want to talk about my
relationships I've dated publicly yeah
so I'm trying to you know date privately
and yeah I mean I love anybody right now
you went to Gigi's grandmother's funeral
with her which was beautiful so it seems
like you really care about her yeah
she's she's an amazing person we've had
great time together
we funk out a few times I think yeah so
you join the modeling thing mm-hmm
is that keeping you super busy traveling
all over the world what's next with that
um I got a really good really big
campaign coming out in January I got
some other things that are coming so I'm
excited
it's fun it's you know it's been crazy
would you and your friend Gigi ever
model together well she works in the
industry do you guys ever cross paths
working uh no she's a little bit more
big-time than I might be one of the
biggest supermodels in the world yes
yeah pretty good at what she does
you met Bella - right I mean do you have
you learned anything from them they've
been in this industry a long time oh no
I don't really try to talk about that
talk with them I just try to enjoy the
moment okay yeah you know again I loved
your respectful King speeches if you
were gonna like say just anything
amazing and beautiful about Gigi what
we'd brought with the speech
she's great anything else that's great I
had someone's leave it at that
okay I mean I could sit here and say
like she's gorgeous she's funny she's
accomplished she's all these things for
me see you - great yeah
can't argue that she's great real quick
I just gotta ask you about out my
Johnson my seemingly I mean he said take
him Demi lavato out on a couple days
that's big time like gain time my son
Mike's a smooth operator is he no he's
got that smile he's got a smile and
there's those little caterpillar
eyebrows he's cute you know maybe it may
be a double date what do you think we'll
see we'll see
Mike's uh you know mice busy guy I'm a
busy guy yeah but uh no I mean I'm happy
for him he seems to be happy and living
life you know to the fullest I know you
you know part want to be the bachelor
but it seems like he's bouncing back all
right and it'll do just fine Mike's
great bouncing back with a superstar
Demi Lovato
[Music]